[Musique]
pour moi bien vivre ensemble demain
c'est une question de volonté et c'est
aussi une question de changement de
perspective d'angles de vue
mais commençons par regarder ensemble la
ville d'aujourd'hui
quel constat pouvons nous faire premier
constat le trafic routier augmente et
toutes les nuisances qui vont avec aussi
bien sur la pollution de l'air augmente
mais aussi la pollution sonore et
l'encombrement des routes
alors d'où vient cette augmentation des
flux routiers et bien dans les grandes
villes
il provient en partie de l'augmentation
du transport des marchandises à domicile
à paris sur cent mille camions qui
rentrent chaque jour dans la ville
seulement deux mille livres des colis à
domicile mais ils représentent un tiers
des mouvements de camions et cela
devrait continuer à croître fortement
parce que c'est directement lié à
l'essor du e-commerce le e-commerce et
+10 9% de transactions chaque année
selon la fevad
deuxième constat le chômage de masse
laisse à l'écart du monde du travail de
nombreuses personnes et ce chômage qui
touche en particulier les personnes peu
qualifiées
là encore je vais prendre l'exemple de
paris a paris il ya 67 mille personnes
inscrites au rsa ça veut dire 60 7000
personnes qui ne travaillent pas
suffisamment qui ne peuvent pas
travailler suffisamment pour subvenir
aux besoins de leur famille alors une
fois qu'on a fait ces constats la vraie
question c'est comment on passe des
problèmes aux solutions et là la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'on peut voir dans ces
tendances des opportunités au fond le
vrai coupable de tout ça c'est le
digital le digital il permet l'essor du
e-commerce il
nous apporte des services plus de
confort mais une fine et génère aussi
des nuisances
or ça ce n'est pas une fatalité
aujourd'hui on peut utiliser le digital
pour livrer autrement remettre l'humain
au centre de la ville et créer des modes
de livraison écologique
c'est comme ça qu'est née la tournée ce
sont des entrepreneurs féru d'innovation
et soucieux du bien commun qui ont
imaginé ce service de livraison urbains
réalisés par des livreurs à pied et moi
je les ai rejoints en 2012 pour
concrétiser cette idée en lançant
l'expérimentation du service alors la
tournée concrètement c'est quoi comme je
voulais dit c'est un service de
livraison écologique qui repose sur
l'humain et sur la proximité
on prend les territoires des grandes
villes et on commence par les découper
par quartier et puis ensuite on met une
équipe de livreurs à pied dans chaque
quartier
à paris on définit ainsi 80 quartiers
mais je vous propose de regarder tout de
suite comment ça fonctionne dans la
vraie vie
première étape la collecte des colis
les livreurs passe chez tous les
commerçants inscrits gratuitement au
service pets des commerces alimentaires
mais aussi du pressing des libraires de
la pharmacie ils prennent le bon de
commande qui se trouve sur chaque colis
si le client est connu du service il
suffit de saisir leur numéro de
téléphone sur l'application et
l'application renvoient toutes les
coordonnées du client
ensuite il met les colis dans son
chariot et il rejoint ses collègues
livrent heures sur une place publique
là c'est la deuxième étape c'est le tri
des colis chaque livreur couvre une
partie du quartier il prend donc les
colis qui concerne sa zone et cet
échange il est tracée sur l'application
mobile ce qui fait qu'à la fin chacun
une carte de livraison qui lui suffit de
suivre pour aller livrer là c'est la
troisième étape la livraison des colis
les livreurs se rendent au domicile de
chaque client et au pied de l'immeuble
ils disposent de toutes les informations
sur leur téléphone pour accéder au
domicile du client
il monte dans les étages ils remettent
le colis en mains propres aux clients là
encore l'échangé géolocaliser sécurisé
et signé par le client sur l'écran du
smartphone et toutes les informations
qu'on a enregistrées elles sont mises à
jour en temps réel sur un site intranet
accessible pour les commerçants les
clients et le management
donc là vous avez vu qu'on a remis
l'humain au centre de la ville est au
centre du service on a essentiellement
des livreurs à pied qui utilisent des
chariots a poussé manuel et ils font les
changes des colis dans la rue à la fin
de la tournée ils gardent leur chariot
sur une place de motos public
on est donc très économe en matériel et
en immobilier
et puis on utilise les nouvelles
technologies pour fluidifier et
sécuriser les flux de livraison ça c'est
ce qu'on a fait sur un quartier de paris
de janvier 2012 à juin 2014
et on a fait ça six jours sur sept avec
deux tournées une le matin et une le
soir sur un quartier qui correspond à
peu près à un quart d'arrondissement
soit quarante mille habitants en terme
de population
qu'est ce qu'on a appris via cette
expérimentation
la chose essentielle qu'on a apprise
c'est que les quartiers des grandes
villes sont de véritables réseaux
sociaux physique qu'il suffit d'activer
via des services comme la tournée pour
obtenir des bénéfices immédiats pour les
habitants je vais vous prendre trois
exemples de bénéficiaires
premièrement les clients actifs je pense
à cette mère de famille qui était chez
elle avec son nourrisson malades et bien
elle a pu se faire livrer des
médicaments sans sortir de chez elle
grâce à la tournée
en effet on a obtenu l'autorisation du
conseil de l'ordre des pharmaciens de
livrer des médicaments sans utiliser la
carte vitale des habitants connue des
pharmacies du quartier et cette
autorisation tout à fait exceptionnel on
l'a obtenu parce qu'on a un ancrage
hyperlocal qu'on fait partie d'un réseau
humain et que ça ça nous interdit ça
nous empêche de détourner le système ou
de mal utilisé
deuxièmement deuxième type de
bénéficiaires les personnes à mobilité
réduite et les seniors
ben ils ont eu deux usages du service un
usage classique donc pour les personnes
qui ne pouvaient plus sortir de chez
elles elles ont passé commande à leurs
commerçants par téléphone et la tournée
les a livrés à domicile
et puis il ya eu un usage qu'on
n'attendait pas forcément celles qui
pouvaient encore sortir mais qui ne
pouvait plus porter leur pack et on leur
a redonné une liberté on a vu des gens
pour recommencer à faire leurs courses
chez les commerçants de quartier et puis
la tournée venait leur apporter les
paquets en fin de matinée ou en fin
d'après-midi troisième type de
bénéficiaires nos livreurs bien sûr
parce que la tournée ça permet de faire
réaliser des livraisons par des
personnes éloignées de l'emploi
et ça ça leur redonne une utilité
sociale auprès des clients et auprès des
commerçants et puis on en fait des
figures connues du quartier nos livreurs
il marche tous les jours dans la rue y
porte un uniforme ils ont des
smartphones et donc on les reconnaît au
même titre que les facteurs ou les
policiers et tous nos livreurs et bien
grâce à cette seule reconnaissance ils
ont progressé ils ont tous trouvé un
emploi après leur passage à la tournée
et puisqu'on a réussi à prouver via
cette expérimentation c'est que on peut
livrer tout type de petits colis sur un
créneau de deux heures sans aucun retard
à l'échelle d'un quartier à pied et en
plus on a fait ça pour 2 euros la
livraison donc ça c'est complètement
disruptif par rapport à tous les prix de
livraison que vous pouvez voir
aujourd'hui les services de coursiers
qui font de la livraison point à point
leurs tarifs de démarrage c'est 5 euros
la livraison et nous avec un système en
tournée on mutualisent les coûts et donc
on arrive à un tarif très bas
ok c'est super là c'est déjà des bons
résultats on est content mais est ce
qu'on a réussi à adresser les deux
problèmes qu'on s'était fixé en point de
mire au départ donc le chômage et la
pollution et bien sûr le chômage j'ai un
peu répondu
la tournée c'est un modèle très insérant
ça permet de remettre durablement dans
l'emploi des personnes qui en étaient
éloignés en revanche sur la pollution là
pour l'instant je vous ai encore rien
prouvé et là c'est la mairie de paris
qui avait une nounou stimuler sur le
terrain voilà parfois on est stimulé
aussi par par les services publics
le directeur de la de la voirie de la
mairie de paris il est venu nous voir au
bout de six mois d'expérimentation et il
nous a dit j'aime bien votre service
mais moi j'ai un problème de santé
publique due aux particules fines émises
par les véhicules polluants donc comment
vous pouvez m'aider à résoudre ce
problème là on lui a dit si on ne prend
en charge que les colis des commerçants
de quartier on n'a aucun impact
en revanche si on dispose d'un échangeur
de colis par quartier c'est à dire 80
échangeur de colis sur tout paris on
peut avoir un impact significatif sur la
pollution
il suffit de demander à tous les gros
transporteurs de colis la poste dhl ups
tnt et j'en oublie de déposer tous leurs
colis dans ces échangeurs et de faire
réaliser les derniers mètres de
livraison par des modes de livraison
écologique
donc ça peut être à pied à vélo en cargo
cycle et puis cette boucle locale
eh bien on peut l'ouvrir à tous les
opérateurs bien sûr on peut l'ouvrir à
la tournée qui fait des livraisons à
pied mais on peut l'ouvrir aussi aux
facteurs de la poste on peut l'ouvrir à
toutes les start up de livraison en vélo
et puis à toutes les entreprises qui ont
des moyens de livraison doux et ça c'est
la tournée version 2 c'est celle qui
permet de passer de la maille quartier à
l'échelle de la ville
et puis en plus c'est pas compliqué
c'est un système simple et vertueux tout
d'abord il est simple parce que il
s'inscrit complètement dans le processus
actuel de livraison des transporteurs
les grands transporteurs aujourd'hui
itri leur colline dans des centres qui
sont situés à l'extérieur de la ville
et puis ils amènent leurs colis en
camion dans la ville donc il pourrait
très bien créer des sacs de colis pour
détourner locale ensuite il est vertueux
parce qu'une fois qu'on a ces échangeurs
de proximité on peut créer plein de
nouveaux services qui correspondent aux
attentes des clients
on peut facilement faire de la livraison
le soir de l'art livraison en cas de non
remise du colis ou de la livraison sur
des créneaux horaires dédiées et quand
on crée de nouveaux services en créer de
nouveaux emplois mais alors vous me
direz c'est super mais comment ça se
fait qu'on vous voit pas déjà sur tout
tout les rues de paris ou d'autres
grandes villes françaises
et bien parce que pour mettre en place
une infrastructure comme la tournée
version 2 il faut faire évoluer toutes
les parties prenantes de l'écosystème
premièrement il faut que les mairies
réglemente pour interdire la circulation
de véhicules polluants de livraison en
centre ville sur de longues plages
horaires deuxièmement il faut que les
gros transporteurs de colis utilise une
infrastructure d'échangeurs mutualiser
et ça c'est pas du tout dans leur
culture
enfin aujourd'hui les clients n'ont pas
l'habitude de demander que le pollueur
soit le payeur donc il ya un travail de
conviction à faire il est assez long
nous ça fait deux ans qu'on mène ce
travail est là on est assez content
parce qu'on n'a jamais été aussi près de
notre but
la mairie de paris est entré en phase
finale d'études de notre service et elle
devrait prendre une décision d'ici au 15
janvier de créer ou pas les 80 échangeur
de colis qui nous permettrait de nous
étendre sur toute la ville donc si je
vous ai convaincus qu'avec de la volonté
et un changement de perspective et
d'angles de vue on peut changer les
choses et mieux vivre ensemble demain
merci de nous apporter ou soutien sur le
twitter de la tournée merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]